so let's begin our next speaker is thank
you for inviting this is being great so
far
so I'll talk about some of my recent
work that I have been doing and hashing
and adaptive something so this is joint
work with my group of PhD students
masters and undergrads I Mantua issue so
I work at Rice University is I'm an
assistant professor there alright so I
mean this is a you know slide from
Michael money stock where you know in
randomized even with a linear algebra
one of the basic pillars is sampling so
you sample the data in some carefully
data dependent manner to reduce the size
of the sketch size of the data and then
do a computation on this reduced matrix
but what I will focus on in many
scenarios and especially in very large
scale up machine learning and signal
processing application the sampling
itself is the computational bottleneck
and if you are thinking how here is a
piece of motivation so you know a
classical example of stochastic gradient
descent so you want to compute you don't
want a computer full gradient because
it's too expensive so you randomly
sample a point and compute the gradient
only on that point and that's an
unbiased estimate for a gradient and you
use this for you know for for your
descent now there are there has been
this question in the literature is there
are there better estimates and if you
are in if you are aware of levers or
sampling another adaptive sampling the
answer is of course yes you should
actually pick some WI you should pick X
I in proportion to some WI which is the
weight which is actually some sort of an
l2 norm of the gradient ideally you
should pick a data which has maximum
impact at this point for your gradient
descent so think of this is a sum right
I really want to pick the heavier
entries of the sum if you want to
estimate a sum as simple as that now so
that's great but how will you do it
because every time whenever you make a
gradient step your parameter changes and
so does these weights so if you think
about it just computing this waves our
order and operation you are better off
computing the full gradient rather than
estimating it so this is some sort of a
chicken and the egg loop and what I'm
going to talk about is that there are
ways in which we can reduce this chicken
and egg loop in I know you know with
having something like in constant
amortized cost so here is the outline of
the talk I'll talk about you know the
the classical LSH algorithm and I'll
introduce what it is and how by just
mere indexing we can do something much
better than random and then I'll show
that we can use this LSH algorithm which
is classically used for sub linear near
neighbor search for for an estimation
problem and even similar you know an
adaptive sampling in deep neural network
which can actually increase the
computation further then I'll just
highlight some of the other projects
that I'm interested in in case you have
any questions okay so I mean I mean when
I say hashing I mean yes you're right if
you're thinking about Java hash map so
what is the hash function a hash
function you know it just takes a data
object of interest so for example
something a vector in R to the power D
it Maps this object to a discrete set so
that's that's what a hash function is
and ideally in literature you want if X
is equal to Y then its hash value should
be equal to you know H of X should be
equal to H of Y and if they are not then
you don't want them to be equal it's the
ideal hash function and if you're
thinking of Java hash map this is what
it is used for there is a you know a
usual interview question is that given
an array of integers and integers you
want to remove duplicates if you try
comparison it's n square if you try
sorting it's n log n but if you use
hashing is bingo F so somehow this
accessing a memory location the pointer
thing accessing a memory location is a
constant time operation this is the
whole reason of you know the use of data
structure and it makes something much
better than what you would have imagined
now this problem stick hashing is also a
hash function except that there are some
points in the hash function and I'll
show you what I mean by those coins but
again the same thing it takes the data
object and maps to a discrete set okay
and this time I relax the definition in
a problem stick way so instead of
wanting X equal to Y and H of X equal to
H of Y I'll say if similarity of x and y
is high that i want the probability of
the agreement of the hash value to be
high and the similarity is low then what
I want is that the probability of hash
and is low so this is this is a
definition they know this is a you know
not the formal definition but you know I
want to give you a notion of what so
that's that's you know called the
locality sensitive hashing or a locality
sensitive property and a lot is known
about such hash functions but basically
what it is saying is that if I have a
data point like this in which these two
points are close and this is far then
under such a mapping I will likely see
this configuration and it is very
unlikely I'll see this combination and
now you might be wondering what this
randomization is so here is a classical
example which is known as sine random
projection so basically this house works
imagine we have four points in the space
green orange blue and black then I
randomly sample a hyperplane passing
through origin so that's where the
randomness comes in the picture and the
hash hash value is simply which side of
hyperplane the points are so these two
gets hash value 1 and these to get hash
value 0 now it's not very difficult at
least in two dimension to see that if
two points are very close in their angle
then no matter how you sample they will
always have the same hash value and in
fact you can formally show that in the
higher dimension that the probability of
agreement of the hash value is a
monotonic function of what is known as
cosine similarity that means if the
cosine similarity is high the
probability of agreement is high and the
cosine similarity is low the probability
of agreement is low and so this is a
classical example of a
locality-sensitive hashing function and
this work comes from a classical result
of governance milem Sun 95 and you know
this is you know two decades of work has
been gone in this and there are many
popular measures that we know exist so
by measure I mean those similarity that
I showed so we know how to consider cash
function project card similarity cosine
similarity you clear in distance or
mobile distance and in fact recently we
have also shown that it's possible even
when you have inner products it is
possible to construct such hash
functions so why what is what is the use
case of this hash function again I have
given your hand it's about indexing so
you know you are given a query and a
giant collection so we are planning to
do some linear near neighbor search with
problem is simple a giant collection is
given I have a query I want to search
this collection for something closest to
the query and of course the worst case
is not very hard it's linear but the
query is a frequent operation and n is
huge so we want something like a sub
linear time algorithm and here is what
the idea is so let's say I have ax
to this magical hash function with this
property that the probability of
agreement is some sort of an indicator
of high similarity then this is what you
can do so let's say this is your data
point is and in the illustration I am
using two independent hash functions so
this could be two sample hyperplanes
let's say the H value is only 0 1 2 3 4
so I pick this orange point compute H 1
and H 2 on this let us say H 1 turns out
to be 0 0 and H 2 turns out to be 0 1
then I'll take this orange point and
place it to the bucket location 0 0 0 1
and similarly I'll do it for all the
points now let's say I get a query then
I'll use the same 2 hash function and
compute so let's say H 1 of query comes
out to be 1 1 and H 2 of query 0 1 now
instead of treating every object in this
database as a candidate the argument is
let me just go to the bucket indexed by
1 1 0 1 and look for caddy it's there
now the argument is that it's a good
bucket why because every element in that
bucket has H 1 equal to 1 1 and H 2
equal to 0 1 so just by a bucket probe
assuming my hash function computations
are fast just buy a bucket probe I'm
guaranteed to find data points which has
agreed on the hash value at least twice
in this case and so I am eating
randomness just buy a bucket lookup if
you know that how the arguments of
boosting work this is essentially
sufficient and in fact this argument can
be boosted so basically in this case 2
is just an illustration I can have K of
them and do not miss probabilistically
the points I can repeat the process a
time so instead of probing one bucket
I'm probing some L number of buckets and
L independent hash table and looking at
the union of the buckets as my candidate
set and basically the theory says that
there is a sweet spot and so if you are
smart about tuning this K and L you can
solve a very particular instance of a
search problem which is called C
approximate search and that is the
classical result from Indyk and what one
if from 98 so this is you know this is
the LS search has been a huge leap
successful you know like algorithm in
both you know industry and Academy are
their similarity search related problems
are being solved you can do to mention
ID reduction you can do similarity
estimation mean either problems and in
fact it won the 2012 ACM Paris connects
theory and practice award and
what we are going to ask is are there
other fundamental problems that we can
solve with this technique okay I have
essentially given you given you the you
know the hint so basically what is
happening is I take a data I have a
query I compute some hash of a query go
to a bucket and I am beating randomness
in fact if you look at the proofs of LSH
here is what it looks like that given a
query Q and if I have K and L parameters
as shown in this picture then what is
happening is I am retrieving any date X
from the data set with precisely this
probability and what is this probability
this is the collision probability the
raise to K is the probability of finding
that element in the bucket 1 - that is
not finding in 1 hash table raised to L
is not finding in any hash table and 1 -
that is finding so you not only know
that it is sample you have retrieved the
point X but you also know what is the
probability of retrieval and in fact
this function is a monotonic function of
the similarity which means that given a
query I will retrieve X 1 with higher
probability compared to X 2 if and only
if the similarity of X 1 with the query
is higher than X 2 and not only that I
also know the probability expression to
me this is huge I am sampling something
from a data structure I know the
probability of sampling and I know it's
adaptive and I can do just by mere
bucket lookup so you know we can do a
lot of things here so again like if you
if you look at Sol SH was considered a
black box for search but I think search
is just one among the possibility
because what we are doing is adaptive
sampling your solving a very you know a
very fundamental problem here so here is
one another motive a motivation
motivating problem so long linear models
is usually popular like word to week
application in which the probability of
a class Y given a context X and
parameters theta is modeled as e to the
power the parameter corresponding to the
class times X divided by a partition
function now this partition function is
just a sum over all possible classes now
if you are thinking about word to work
this is a summation over billions unique
partition function both for inference
and computing the gradient so this is an
expensive operation so you want to
estimate the
petition function without doing a lot of
work there has been a lot of work around
it so one thing is okay it's a summation
so summation can be approximated by
estimation expectation sorry so if you
could sample the classes in proportion
to there's probability then you just
take few samples add them up you're done
but hang on for a second how do I sample
with this quantity because this quantity
itself first I have to compute the
weights and sample so that's that that
beats the whole purpose because we want
to be linearity and this is linear to
just even know the weights and the
weights change with context so that's
that's another ratio so well the
literature says okay if you cannot
sample from here there's something
called important sampling so you sample
from some proposal G and then you know
at just your weight so that you still
get an unbiased estimator but again
there is some sort of a chicken and an
egg loop it doesn't quite work unless G
is close to F so here is the dilemma I
want to sample from F I cannot so I go
to a proxy but the proxy should be as
good as the original to get anything
interesting and then basically there is
no efficient choice in literature so
what people do is random sampling in
practice but imagine you have this is a
power law and you are doing a random
sampling it's going to be a very bad
aesthetic power law is common in word to
that kind of scenarios so okay like as I
mentioned here's what we are going to do
we are going to take all these theta Y's
and put them into the hash table and
whenever a current context arrive I'm
going to prove few buckets and sample
from the bucket and then since I know
the probability of the sampling I should
be able to construct an estimator now
there is some caution here is that the
samples are correlated and not
normalized so it's not quite important
sampling but that doesn't stop us if you
know how expectation works expectation
doesn't worry anything about you know
you can just you know the probability of
sampling you know what you're sampling
so you can actually construct an
unbiased estimator so there so you know
basically you put all throw you pre
process so you pay a one-time cost of
pre-processing your parameters into the
hash table then given the context you go
to few buckets get some elements from
there and you construct this estimate
now you can show that this is unbiased
it's simple
the various looks something
so this variance is like a random
sampling variance and this is because of
the correlations in LSH but if you look
at this term it says that if a randomly
sampled pair is likely to be in the same
bucket then this quantity will be
positive otherwise it will be negative
so this is a very big negative term so
we are going to get better variance than
random sampling and it's also not very
difficult I have a sum which has heavy
entries and not so heavy entries and the
probability of retrieving heavier
entries is more than probability of
entering not heavy entry so I should get
better estimators so in fact if you are
using a hash function for inner products
so remember our this thing is monotonic
in N our product so if I have a hash
function where the sampling is monotonic
in an odd product I am guaranteed that
if the optimal sampling prefers X 1 over
X 2 then so does my sampling and
basically the modes are the same and you
can get an efficient estimation how does
it work so this is two data set which is
basically you are doing the word to back
kind of thing and this is penn treebank
and textaid data set with like a million
and 100 million words so what you are
trying to do is you we are fitting a
language model and we are measuring the
goodness of fit using what is known as
the perplexity and this is a snapshot of
what happens in between so what we are
doing is we are estimating the partition
function using uniform sampling this is
what it is uniform sampling is very fast
think about it flip a coin pick an
element now said sampling is also very
fast you can see roughly same cost as
uniform sampling you are computing a
hash function like a sparse hash
functions going to a bucket picking few
points from there that's also roughly as
fast it has much better accuracy than
random sampling so here is the number of
samples and here is the mean average
estimator now there are two other
methods which are put in dotted slit
based on the max kumble trick and you
know using efficient LS set for those
tricks but those tricks are like
horribly expensive you can see the
amount of time it requires for
estimation and if you do approximation
it even diverges now a uniform is
slightly faster than Alice edge but you
can see that the in terms of the
perplexity it has a very bad because of
the bad estimation it gives back
perplexity where LSH almost comes close
to the standard which is the gold
standard what we are looking but what I
want you to focus on this and this is
random sampling
so again like so here is something to
note about a lot of people say that oh
we could use near neighbour search so
for near neighbour search you have to
construct many buckets if you know the
theory of LSH you have to construct
several buckets take a candidate set do
a candidate filtering and get the top
key you're doing a lot of work in
candidate filtering you could have
utilized that but again like you need a
lot of hash tables now for sampling even
one table will work because one table is
still greeting randomness now there's an
interesting trade-off of how many tables
you want to use and how much you want to
beat randomness but there is a whole
knob of computation versus accuracy
there so that's why sampling is way more
efficient and that is why you can see
you know this speed otherwise if you are
not then it's here I think we are using
ten or fifteen tables or even less than
that and here is this thing in for STD
we just use you know one table or
something it still works so okay like
remember I told you this application I
have I have to estimate the gradient
using one random sample or what I can do
is use some sort of LSH so remember the
variance optimal variance sampling is
some sort of an l2 norm of the gradient
now for linear regression this l 2-norm
resolves something like this now if you
think about this this is a data this
terms depends on the rate and this
depends on the parameter which changes
so what I can do is I can throw this
thing which is more or less fixed into
the hash table every time with the
parameter I query the hash table get a
sample from the bucket and divided by
the sampling probability if you're smart
about what hash functions you are using
your hash a your per cost is roughly one
point five times the cost of STD so here
is one experiment as how good the
gradients are so on the X or the y axis
is the cosine similarity of the true
gradient with the estimated gradient an
estimation being random or a less such
based the random is blue LSH based is
right so you're getting better and this
is the number of samples so number of
sample reduces the variance so you're
seeing that they are constantly getting
better estimates of the gradient and
what does it translate into this so what
is going on here left is a algorithm
called a de Graaff the right is
algorithm called as Gini the only thing
that has changed is the gradient
estimate so I say that
your favorite descent algorithm Adam a
digraph now you will use a random sample
to estimate a gradient I'll give you a
less of a is gradient so the only thing
that has changed is the gradient the
blue is the random sampling based
gradient and the red is the telus hbase
carried now the dotted is best and the
bold strain and this is the running time
and this is the power so if pop wise you
are beating in convergence is fine
because you're getting better estimate
but if pop wise convergence is not
impressive because I could use Newton's
to get a clockwise convergence but I'm
also getting roughly similar kind of
convent behavior even in running time
and that is because I'm only paying 1.5
times the cost of SGD so my update cost
is roughly roughly 1.5 times and
remember as GD is fast you flip up you
flip a coin pick a sample do your update
meeting that is hard so again like you
know so basically what what fundamental
problem that we attack is B if you are
given some sort of a time evolving
weights and you want to yes linear
regression sorry so given n time
evolving weights
I want to sample every time in
proportion to these weights if these
weights has a specially specific form
very specific then I think the sum of
the sampling is efficient okay
so till now we have been what we have
been doing is there was a fixed part
which was data we hash it in the hash
table look at the context or the
parameter and sample now we will turn
the tables around and the motivation is
we want to do large-scale neural
networks so again like this phenomena is
you know familiar with everyone we need
larger networks and larger data size to
achieve better accuracy and of course
there's tons of engineering and back
propagation now you know we have started
getting more and more ambitious we want
neural networks to predict everything
now basic information theory says that
if I have a model that has information
about almost everything it cannot be
small and therefore neural network sizes
are growing and it's not it's not
surprising that last year Google
reported of 137 billion parameter neural
network which was called one model for
all it does text images and speech all
together now propagation as you know
there is a consensus among the field
that the current back propagation is not
sustained
because of many too slow training and
validation it starts the scientific
process it requires expensive clusters
not everybody can be use it the memory
and energy are out of bounds for IOT
applications and there's too slow for
latency critical applications if you're
predicting click and a very large
network is passing through it it's not
happening in few milliseconds even with
you know the kind of computation power
we have so there are a lot of other
approaches but one thing that is there
is so imagine I have a billion neurons
network or billion parameter Network and
I'm only showing an image of a cat is it
going to change my belief about all the
parameters the answer is no if it's
changing the belief that means my whole
learning is like you know somehow you
know it so ideally it only changes the
parameters that is relevant to this
input so it essentially becoming a
search and an adaptive sampling problem
in disguise and in fact there was a work
in nips 2014 that shows that in a neural
network with input layer and a hidden
layer and the activation is a monotonic
function of the inner product what they
did was they took every data point
compute all the activation and only few
pick very few neurons based on some sort
of a Bernoulli sampling and did feed
forward and back propagation only on
those neurons so basically you take a
very smart snapshot of a network based
on some sort of a sampling and they show
that this leads to better generalization
but computationally it's not very
lucrative because it does the full cost
of training and testing so first you
compute all the activation you have done
all the work then you do the sampling
and then do then specify the network for
training and testing now again it says
from the context of the talk this is
what we are going to do so this time so
there is so that's that's one oh so this
is very difficult thanks for that this
is very different so it's not like I'm
specifying a network every input picks a
different set of neurons so a cat will
pick cat neurons a car will pick car
neurons and that's sufficient for
training and testing is not just
sufficient it's even better for
generalization so here is how we are
going to make this efficient so we know
that we are going to sample but instead
of using a Bernoulli sampling I'm going
to replace it with a very
unusual distribution but what is so here
let's say I have this original neural
network I take this layer throw all the
neurons into the hash tables similarly I
do it at every layer so this time I'm
not hashing data
I am hashing neurons into the hash table
neurons are just weight vectors now
let's say I get an input then I hash the
input and go to certain bucket and only
pick the nodes that are there in those
bucket and these are just pointers so
basically I get to know just by few
bucket lookups I know the spasticity
pattern of the network and what I will
do is I will only feed forward on this
and back propagate and then once I have
back propagated I will update the
weights in the hash tables so my order
of computation the complexity of
computation is the order of the active
neurons rather than the total number of
parameters and if you believe that the
active mean the network's can go very
sparse and the number of neurons can be
much less than the total you know the
total size of the network then it is
going to be very efficient so here's
what some plots are so these are four
different data sets on the x-axis is
what is the person the fraction of
neurons that are active or the fraction
of parameters that I'm using in every
SGD you know back propagation epoch the
black line is the neural network fully
connected neural network this is two
fully connected layer thousand thousand
nodes in each layer the two dotted lines
are the expensive method which is using
the sampling idea so that the computer
all the activation to do Bernoulli
sampling and stuff the pink line is
random sampling I don't care about any
adaptiveness I will randomly pick
neurons it's efficient but it doesn't
lead to good accuracy and the blue line
is there less such base something now
this pink line at 50% becomes dropout
because that's that's what dropout is
but then what you can see is we can even
work with five or 10% sparsity in a
thousand layer neuron and get roughly
the same accuracy as the original
network as the network goes bigger for
example if I have million or a billion
layers then it it's even more efficient
because I just need only few
confuse we're hashing rehash the weight
vectors for each neuron yes what's our
distance function well I'm using another
product hashing so my distance function
is just inner product and I know that
activations are monotonic inner product
so I want to pick large activation as
then I want to pick large inner products
and that is what we know so so so this
is going to the hash tables the neurons
and the input is the query time so
basically I hash this I go here then I
get a sparse representation here I hash
this bastard a representation goes to
the next layer and so on and so forth
I'm sorry I you know yes yes and this is
what the results look like so I got in a
product so the hash function is catering
the inner product similarity so I'm
guaranteed that if there is a hash
agreement the naina product will be
higher and based on that I can create a
hash tables so now this is this is good
so I can make the networks very sparse
right so I can make the network very
sparse the computations are less and
there's a bonus here it's a synchronous
parallelism so if imagine I have a cat
input and a car input and they are
activating a very sparse set of neurons
they are unlikely to overlap so I can
basically do STD in parallel I think we
had a top that shows that we need
smaller bath size and the parallelism
these days is just based on the bath
size because the matrix multiplication
here I'm going away from matrix
multiplication and talking about hash
tables now hash tables are something
which databases people have mastered
over two decades it's efficient this
algorithm is efficient and plus it's
paralyze able in the number of inputs so
as you get more and more input so this
is basically shows the convergence with
one thread eight thread and 56 threads
all doing a synchronous gradient descent
without any synchronization and you can
see the running time goes straight down
with the number of processors and but
the convergence is not affected but if
you do the dance I also have those plots
in the paper that the convergence is
affected if you do dense
accuracy for fairies to ground to Thor
to the best you could do if you train
the whole network so this accuracy plot
is with respect to the best you can do
with the network yeah but there is
something weird here sometimes with
randomization you want exactly and that
is what I was very interested about mic
start because we could actually test
this and see if this is a regularization
which I suspect is a regularization also
random regularization yes yes I you know
that's that's very exciting so you see
this phenomenon right and you see this
often actually so yeah and so that's you
know so there are other projects that
I'm involved with I've been using like
sketching algorithms for you know K
class classification like extreme
classification is log memory so you can
actually sketch the classes we can do
feature selection using count sketches
in log be memory then we had a recent
paper in EPS which is talked about how
we can reduce the heap so you have we
can avoid using heaps and distributed
computing so count sketches if you want
to get the top K you need a heap data
structure and that creates some problem
when you are you know merging across
threads so we can get rid of that and
then I'll recently I'm also very excited
about so now once you go to a bucket you
sample you also know the probability I
think we can design efficient proposals
for Bayesian estimation using hashing so
you know these are all the projects I'm
interested in here is a quick peek on
how we do large-scale feature selection
so imagine you are doing a regression
and you want to only you cannot afford a
memory which is of the order of the
dimensions so imagine D like this is the
the application was DNA datasets you
have like hundreds of billions of
dimensions so that's like a terabyte of
data just to store a weight vector so
you can afford sparsity but you cannot
afford a dense vector so if you take an
example an example is just a sequence so
it's very small it's very sparse so as
judy is possible but at some any point
of time you cannot if it start becoming
dense you have to threshold or do
something else here is the better way to
do it you start with a count sketch the
gradient descent is a linear operator
and sketching is linear so some of
sketches is sketches of some so
basically every time you get you get a
gradient you push it to the sketch and
to get the parameter you just query the
sketch and the sketch could be any
compressed sensing structure but count
sketches are nice because
they have like very fast update and
query time we actually showed we could
do a feature selection on 2.3 billion
dimensions and it was much better than a
hard thresholding based approaches which
is the only other thing we could try on
that yourself so you know these are the
kind of stuff that I'm interested in the
stock I mainly focused on computations
but there are a whole spectrum of work
based on memory which I won't have time
to go into it but I will be happy to
talk there wise here are the references
that that are associated with what I
said and I will glued that this is a
perfect time for algorithmic disruption
in large-scale machine learning because
that's kind of a consensus that the
current techniques are not sustainable
especially when it comes to deep
learning and I think if you revisit old
algorithm with a new perspective then
there are a lot of hopes and again
probabilistic hashing and randomization
is a great tool and that's why this is
also a great workshop in training do you
end up with this partial network
business partial set of final trade
waves so what you're saying is you drop
completely the neurons I just trained my
network and it's like tense with all the
views being non-zeros all right right
and then you do this trick and you have
a different W or your W sparsa we
haven't touched that part yeah but I
think it's interesting one thing we
could do is take a network train network
and then find the unit using this
approach to make the inference efficient
because this also makes inference
efficient
I'm against so okay so here this is so
this is I'm not I'm not comparing
against a tiger dad so I'm asking okay
you have your favorite grade in descent
algorithm whatever it is give it to me
and the only thing I'll change is your
gradient descent algorithm we'll use a
random sample to estimate the gradient I
will use a less a sample to estimate the
gradient so you think of a gradient
estimator as an Oracle generally people
use random sampling I'll use alexis
sampler okay and the plots here is one
is this is a degrade algorithm and this
is a serial so so one is so the blue
line is the usual a digraph which uses
random sample and then the red line is
the add a graph that uses the Oracle
which uses a Lesage so the only thing
that has change in the two algorithm is
just the the Oracle so this I think is
also a fair comparison because we are
not you know because these things are
very sensitive to a whole bunch of
things
just one short question I don't have
anyone else the regularization effect
that you observe does it depend on the
number of tables tables you know so the
way we do it right now is because if you
see if you just use one hash table it's
it's kind of you know not enough
randomization so what you do actually is
you have a whole bunch of hash tables
then at quit during the run time you
randomly pick few hash tables and take
buckets from there so this way you mix
enough especially there is duty because
you otherwise once you create a hash
table you will get biased obviously in
theory it doesn't matter because you
flip the coin before or later it's fine
but in practice the structure is decided
based on tables so right now we have
like let's say 20 tables and during
query time we randomly go to one of the
hash table and pick a bucket from there
so that that but I think that's an
interesting question is that how it
depends on the hash tables
[Applause]